FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to the episode number
eight of the Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my co-host, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good, thanks.
How you doing, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty
good, pretty good.
Back to San Francisco and
enjoying the awesome weather.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I'm back in San Francisco, too.
It's a little bit warmer than
where I've been previously.
So pretty happy about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I remember you were
in Vancouver, so yeah.
I can imagine.
So we have a very interesting
episode coming today.
We're going to be interviewing
one of our dear teammates.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, Felipe .
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Felipe Hoffa.
He's a developer advocate for
the Google Cloud Platform,
like both of us, but he's
specializes in big data.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
He does some really interesting
stuff with big data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're going
to be talking about big data.
What is big data, why is it
cool, what can you do with it,
what can you do regarding big
data on Google Cloud Platform.
All of those things.
MARK MANDEL: Big data
is hot right now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think it can be
really interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
we're going to try
to discuss as much as possible.
But again, if people
have extra questions,
we're always
interested in those.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
If people want to get in
contact with us, let's
hit them up right now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let's go with that.
So if I remember correctly,
on Twitter it's @GCPpodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On Reddit we
have a subreddit, r/gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
There's a theme here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We have a webpage.
It's. gcppodcast.com.
We have an email,
hello@gcppodcast.com.
And you can find this on
Google Plus as gcppodcast--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's +GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: +GCPpodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
There you go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Easy.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
So yes, if you have any
questions or anything else you
want to send to us, please do.
We love to get the
comments and the feedback.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Cool.
So before we start
with the interview
to our dear colleague,
Felipe, let's
talk about the cool
thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: We have a very
cool, cool thing of the week--
but we're a little
biased, of course--
it's that we took a
pretty cool product,
but we decided just
to make it better.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I know the joke.
It doesn't really work
with your accent, though.
MARK MANDEL: It doesn't
work with my accent.
So currently, in Beta--
or it's Beta-- oh god,
I just ruined it.
But yeah, we have version
2 of our Cloud SQL product.
Do we want talk a little
bit about what Cloud SQL is?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
So Cloud SQL is basically
just MySQL on the cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That's really it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
pretty much what it is.
It has some really
cool features,
like the fact that
you don't need to care
about that instance working.
That's on us.
So you basically say, hey,
I need one instance running.
And if there's any patches
or security or whatever
it needs to be done, it's Google
engineers will do that for you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And if you want to replicate
it and do that stuff like that,
it's sort of just push button.
It's just really easy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Everything is-- basically,
it's like a self-driving MySQL
instance on the cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
And now we have version 2,
which is in beta and better.
You see, with my accent?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
With your accent that
works, yeah, totally.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So what's
new with the beta version?
MARK MANDEL: So basically,
really, it is just better.
So it's a lot faster.
I have a number here.
It was, I believe,
up to seven times
faster than the current
version, which is pretty good.
And you know, like
you don't really
have to do very much
above and beyond that.
And also, it takes-- it
scales out a whole lot better,
up to 20 times the storage
capacity of first generation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I actually saw,
there's a graphic--
we'll put that in
the show notes here--
but there's a graphic where
it shows how much it scales.
And when you have enough traffic
where having 64 course helps,
you're going to see
that it scales--
it's much, much faster.
It's able to have a way higher
transaction per second count
than v. 1.
There's also, yeah, storage.
It used to be 500
gigabytes, which is decent.
MARK MANDEL: It's all right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Now
it's 10 terabytes.
MARK MANDEL: That's
pretty decent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which
is pretty decent.
That's a decent amount of data.
So yeah, and that's
pretty much it.
It's still beta, so all the
features are still not there.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
we're working on them.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So if
you're interested in MySQL
and on the cloud,
just give it a try.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let
us know how it goes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's pretty straightforward.
When you go to
create your instance,
just choose second
generation and away you go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome, great.
So let's go with our interview.
MARK MANDEL: Let's
talk to Felipe.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're here
with our colleague Felipe.
Hi, Felipe.
FELIPE HOFFA: Hello, Francesc.
Hello, Mark.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
there is Felipe Hoffa.
Tell us a little bit
about yourself, Felipe.
Who are you, what do you do?
FELIPE HOFFA: My
name is Felipe Hoffa.
I'm a cloud developer advocate.
I talk a lot about big
data, especially BigQuery.
I started at Google
almost five years ago.
Five years ago, I was
interviewing at this stage.
I started as a
software engineer.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yes, like me right.
MARK MANDEL: Not like me.
FELIPE HOFFA: Not like you,
yes, we have a similar story.
And then, two years later, I
joined the developer relations
team, and I became a software
engineer with a license
to speak.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: With
a license to speak.
MARK MANDEL: I like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's very modest.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
going to use that.
FELIPE HOFFA: I said it first.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So you said that you'd
talk a lot about big data.
So we're going to ask
you just to do that.
Tell us what is big
data, for you at least?
FELIPE HOFFA: What is big data?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
A lot of people have tried to
who define what is big data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
what's your definition?
MARK MANDEL: What
is the definition?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Actually, yeah, what
is the absolute definition?
FELIPE HOFFA: OK,
we are at Google.
We are at Google.
You know how we call
big data at Google?
MARK MANDEL: Data.
Nice.
FELIPE HOFFA: We call it data.
It being big is a
very weird concept.
Data has no size or weight.
Some people called big data
problems that are complicated.
For example, I
love to ask people
when I go to a conference,
who here works in big data?
Normally, people have
no idea if they do.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: But then
asked them questions like,
who knows SQL?
People that know
SQL are people that
are working with
data, with databases.
MARK MANDEL: Fair enough.
FELIPE HOFFA: Then
my next question
is, who has had queries that
ran for more than an hour,
for a day, or that
simply don't run?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
I can see, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: And that's when we
enter a different domain where
problems are taking a
long time, when problems
are complex to solve, at least
with the technologies they
know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So rather than look
at it from like this
is how much terabytes or
petabytes or millions of rows,
rather look at it from
the perspective of,
I've got a problem,
I need to solve it,
when it has to do with data.
But it's going to take
me three hours a day,
a week, given the tools
that I have at my disposal.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
That's what people think, oh,
this is that big data problem.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FELIPE HOFFA: Then we
have the Google way
of solving problems we where
we bring the same problem here
with technologies we have
created, developed here.
And the same problem
that might take you days
using your standard toolkit,
might take you 30 seconds.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Right, nice.
So big data, finally,
it's not really
about the size of the data.
It's really about
how much time it
takes you to solve a problem.
And how like standard
techniques, at some point
they're just not-- they just
don't work anymore, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So what kind
of techniques do you use then?
FELIPE HOFFA: More
than techniques.
At this time it's
about what tools.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: For a while, to
be able to manage terabytes,
of billions of rows, people had
to learn are new technologies.
We have, for example, MapReduce,
Hadoop, [INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
But then there is a lot
of complexity there.
You need to wrap your mind
around using parallel servers,
using developing
[INAUDIBLE] algorithms,
but sometimes you just
want to count things.
You just want to know what
are your top customers,
or how things are changing.
So instead of going through
all these technologies,
today you can use technologies
like a query, where you just
load your data, ask
your question with SQL,
and you get the
answer in seconds,
without having to learn
a whole new mindset.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So you mentioned that
one of the things that we
know about Google is we
have internal problems,
we solve them, and then we put
them as available to anyone
else outside.
Is big query one of those?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah,
well, historically we've
been publishing
all these papers.
The [INAUDIBLE] paper, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
We've been through that, yes.
And one of those people
of those papers is Dremel.
How do we process terabytes
of data using SQL at scale?
And that paper explains
the whole detail
of how do we parallelize
this task without making it--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
We'll put that
definition-- yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, so--
MARK MANDEL: That's
really interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
yeah, historically, we
release the papers.
And the world rushes
to implement them,
with open source
implementations.
But now we have Google Cloud.
Now we make these
services-- the same services
we use internally--
available for everyone.
And that's what we're
doing with BigQuery.
That's the service that
implements the Dremel paper.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
something-- I actually
heard a story about Dremel.
I don't know if it's true or
if it's just like a legend.
But I heard about the fact
that when Dremel was created
at Google, to process
24 hours of logs,
was taking almost
which means that it's taking--
processing one hour of logs
takes more than one
hour, then you're
MARK MANDEL: You're going to--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: At
some point, you're
going to have list [INAUDIBLE].
Like is that true like the good
Dremel solves that problem?
Like all of a sudden,
instead of hours,
you go down to
minutes or seconds?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, yes.
I have no idea if that is true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I've heard it.
FELIPE HOFFA: I know it's
true for many customers.
I know-- I know people who
are working with huge data
sets that were only able to
process a small percentage
of their logs.
And through processes
that ran all night
and failed during the night.
And suddenly, they try
BigQuery and wow, yeah,
it takes five seconds
and no babysitting
of processes or anything.
MARK MANDEL: So
big query really is
like an example of what you
were talking about before.
People struggling
up against walls
of how much time processing
was going to take.
And suddenly going from hours,
days, weeks down to seconds.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
without involving
any special knowledge.
MARK MANDEL: It's just
SQL and that's it.
FELIPE HOFFA: Just SQL, yes.
MARK MANDEL: You don't
have to worry about--
FELIPE HOFFA: We are
just looking about data.
You have data, you
have questions.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
how do you-- how do
you put that data in BigQuery?
FELIPE HOFFA: There
are two main ways.
One is batches.
If you have a CSV
or JSON files, you
can load them into
Google Cloud Storage,
if they are big enough.
So it's good to go through
Google Cloud Storage, when
you have very big files.
You can store them there,
and BigQuery can easily
ingest files from these places.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
FELIPE HOFFA: Or also, big
query can ingest streaming data.
So if you have any stream
of real time data coming,
you can load up to 100,000
rows per second into one
big query table.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That sounds a lot
like what we were discussing
last episode about messaging.
We were talking
about Cloud Pub/Sub.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Is that the way
to stream data into BigQuery?
FELIPE HOFFA: That's one way.
Now, Cloud Pub/Sub
doesn't output data
straight int BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: Don't ask
me why, but maybe one day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Lovely.
We'll fix that.
FELIPE HOFFA: One
of our customers
wrote a very nice
blog post where
they used Pub/Sub to ingest
a lot of streaming data.
They found a lot
goes into BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Now, in the
middle they used Dataflow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes,
Google Cloud Dataflow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Actually, since we're
already discussing
about Cloud Dataflow,
so BigQuery is one
of the products
that you can do big data
processing with Google Cloud
Platform.
What about Cloud Dataflow?
What is the difference and why I
would you use one or the other?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
So if you have data,
you have questions
that you can express with
SQL, BigQuery is the place.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Cool.
FELIPE HOFFA: Now,
with Dataflow,
we are able to solve
different kinds of problems
like where you would code-- you
would use java code to write
more complicated stages.
MARK MANDEL: Is it
more like MapReduce or?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
Dataflow is the new MapReduce.
We published the MapReduce
paper like 10 years ago?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Maybe more.
It was awhile ago.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: And since
then, we published
two very interesting papers.
One is Flume-- FlumeJava.
And that talks about
how we orchestrate
these pipelines of MapReducers
and optimize them on the way.
And also the MillWheel paper
that deals with streaming data.
And Dataflow is our service that
encapsulates these two ideas.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: How do we write
a smart pipeline of MapReduce
processes?
So MapReduce has its problems.
If you really want your
MapReduce processes to go fast,
you have to do a lot
of manual optimization.
And Dataflow takes care of that.
And you just write
your pipelines
as you could write
them mentally.
And then the optimization
is part of the process.
You don't have to care about
optimizing things manually.
MARK MANDEL: So
what sort of things
would I be using Dataflow for?
Like if I can get my
data to be [INAUDIBLE]
and process it there, like can
you give me an example of like,
is it like real time?
Or is it like what sort of
stuff am I doing with Dataflow?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
So Dataflow has two--
we'll say two modes.
One is a batch mode--
MARK MANDEL: OK.
And what is that?
FELIPE HOFFA: And one
is a streaming mode.
MARK MANDEL: So
what's the difference?
FELIPE HOFFA: Well, just
to-- the difference-
what's the difference?
Part of the charm of Dataflow
is that your same code could
work for both types of data.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA:
Usually people have
to deal with one system
for batch processing
and one system for
streaming processes.
With Dataflow, you can do both.
Just to give you a simple
example of what I use Dataflow
for, when I found some web
logs that were in binary format
that I wanted to
load into BigQuery,
I needed to write some code.
The logs were massive,
it was millions of rows.
So I had to process
them in parallel.
So I could write just a
simple script in Java,
inside Dataflow.
And Dataflow took care of doing
this process of splitting it
and writing it into
many different servers.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So using it as sort of--
do data transformations.
FELIPE HOFFA: Data--
MARK MANDEL: Just massive
data transformations.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
Dataflow takes care of
the parrellization--
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FELIPE HOFFA: And making
this process smart..
But what's really brilliant
about Dataflow too,
is how it treats streaming data.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: So I mentioned
that you can stream data
into BigQuery and you can
analyze it later, immediately,
with queries.
But sometimes you want run
some online algorithms.
I love the Wikipedia
example where
you can look at the change log.
So how many-- what
pages are people
changing at any given time?
And the question there
is, from a stream of--
like you have a list of
what pages are changing
on Wikipedia at any time.
How can you find what
are relevant use?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: So how can you
tell this change is important,
versus this change is not.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So you could do something quite
similar like trending topics
on Twitter and stuff like that.
That's really interesting.
MARK MANDEL: That makes sense.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
So there's a Googler,
Thomas Steiner,
that wrote a paper on this.
And he looks at three things.
Is this page-- how
many changes this page
have had in the last minute?
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FELIPE HOFFA: And how
many different people
are changing it.
And there was a third
factor that I-- so it's
how many changes,
how many people,
and how frequent
are these changes.
Once we for surpass
those thresholds,
we can say, oh, now we
have something interesting.
Like we have 50 people at the
same time doing that, changes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yep.
FELIPE HOFFA: I
would love to run
that I algorithm on
a stream of data,
just to get real time results.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That'd be really interesting.
I can even imagine using
that for monitoring
of your own application.
Like trying to understand--
like same thing
you can do monitoring on Google
Cloud Platform of our logs.
And see like, oh, maybe
the traffic is too high.
Send me an alarm.
Or you could do
something more advanced.
MARK MANDEL: Like
business metrics.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Business metrics.
MARK MANDEL: How much money is
being sold-- like being spent,
and their products being sold.
So that sort of stuff.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
with Dataflow, you
have the ability to define
some rules over some window
sessions, time.
It makes it very, very
easy to start defining
that kind of processes.
MARK MANDEL: Now I want to
play with Dataflow more.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Dataflow
is actually the only reason
why I've written Java lately.
Yeah, which you know
it's going-- yeah.
That's a big statement for me.
FELIPE HOFFA: We also
announced a Python Dataflow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I heard about that.
FELIPE HOFFA: But
still not there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: So write
java in the meantime.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So we've discussed two things,
BigQuery and Cloud Dataflow.
I know-- and now that
you mentioned Python,
you made me think about
it-- it's the Cloud Datalab.
FELIPE HOFFA: Datalab-- Datalab.
Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
depending on who you are.
MARK MANDEL: Depending on
which accent in the room
you're going to go with.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
By the other way, accent-wise
today, we're doing--
MARK MANDEL: We're
almost at a-- we
haven't got quite a whole
set, but we're getting close.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, we're very good.
FELIPE HOFFA: I didn't tell
people where I come from.
I'll let them guess.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
That's-- yeah.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Use
big data analysis
to guess where Felipe is from.
So yeah, tell us
about Cloud Datalab.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
So if you have used
the IPython Notebooks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I've done that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: They're cool.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
And you should call them
now the Jupyter Notebooks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, I will.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's the--
that's the actual name now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
IPython split this
project between IPython
and the Notebook.
And now it's the
Jupyter Notebook,
because they support
many more languages.
It's not Python
specifically anymore.
MARK MANDEL: Ah, nice.
Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
I didn't know that.
MARK MANDEL: Did not
know that either.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
the Jupyter name
comes from Julia, Python, and R.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
would make sense.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Something like that.
Yeah.
Cool.
FELIPE HOFFA: So if you take
those notebooks-- I love them.
They're a great way
for data scientists
to work with code,
data, et cetera.
If you take those notebooks,
how can we make them
as-- package them as a service?
How could we have a service
that immediately deploys
a notebook for you,
takes care of storage,
of storing-- leave
them in a repository.
It takes care of authentication
with the different Google
services.
Basically, the Google
Cloud Datalab--
it's an easy way
to deploy, manage,
and work with Google Services
inside Jupyter Notebook.
MARK MANDEL: So if I'm
like, I have all this data.
I want to integrate it with
some of the big data tools,
but I want to like
work in like say
a Python environment,
or an R environment,
and something like that.
And then get like maybe
nice visualizations
and that sort of thing, that's
a pretty good environment
for that?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Perfect.
FELIPE HOFFA: A cool
interactive environment.
Yeah, you could do the same
at home with the old Jupyter
Notebooks, but then
you need to take
care of everything--
installing them,
authentication between your
computer and the server.
With this, they are
just running their--
MARK MANDEL: It's just easy.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
I love them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds really powerful,
especially for education
and things like that.
Where basically, you want
to teach someone statistics.
And you have data.
It's like you can share it.
That sounds really interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
It's one of the best ways
we have now to tell people,
this is how you can
work with data Google.
There are some very interesting
models, for example,
for working with genomics.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: We have a lot
of genomics data on BigQuery.
And the genomics team has
published very cool Datalab
models.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really cool.
Especially what I like
is that, basically, it
allows you to do processing
on what people are already
used to.
Like many people that do data
science, they use Python.
And they used to use IPython,
now they use Jupyter.
So basically, having
the possibility
of doing the same
thing, but having--
being powered by the
cloud and having access
to-- do you have also
access to BigQuery?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So you have access to BigQuery.
Do you have access--
not to Cloud Dataflow,
because that's a
different technology.
That's completely
different, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: What
about Python Dataflow?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, interesting.
So can you actually
combine all of those things
on one single Jupyter thing?
FELIPE HOFFA: You
should be able to.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: We're moving
forward to getting that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Just-- yeah, a
little announcement.
Well, it's not really
an announcement,
but that Cloud Datalab
is still in beta.
So if people want
to play with it,
go see it and give
your feedback.
Like when you give
feedback about data product
is when your feedback is
going to be really taken
into account.
So if you have strong opinions
about the project, let us know.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
Please try it out.
Most of it is open
source, so it's
on-- you can find it on GitHub.
You can file a feature request.
You can send batches
if you follow the whole
how to contribute
code to Google steps.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: That's very cool.
Now, I'm looking here and
apparently, we currently
support what is a Python,
SQL and JavaScript
for query user-defined
functions.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: But it's also like,
pay for the resources you use.
So you could fire this
up and then run with it,
and then shut it down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's really nice.
Cool.
OK.
So, so far we've seen then
Cloud Dataflow, Cloud Datalab,
and BigQuery.
Is there any other products that
you think we should mention?
I mean, we also mentioned
Pub/Sub quite quick.
Is there anything else that you
would like to mention about?
FELIPE HOFFA: It's just fun
to see so many different names
that people have to remember.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
They we all be in
the show notes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Usually
when I say BigQuery,
people will remember
Bigtable for some reason.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh.
Should we talk about Bigtable?
FELIPE HOFFA: We should
mention Bigtable.
Bigtable is awesome.
Bigtable is also
another technology
that, from the beginnings of
Google, we published a paper.
There were all--
those papers, they
produce open source
software based on need
like Hdfs and Cassandra.
And then many
years later, we are
offering Bigtable as service.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
it's Hdfs compatible.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really cool.
I mean, I think that anyone
that has been working at Google
as a software engineer, one of
the things that you get to do
is you get to write
stuff on Bigtable.
It's such an amazing
thing to have,
that I'm actually really
excited to be able to use it
from the outside now.
That you can basically
write your own project
that uses Bigtable.
That's going to be-- That's
going to be very nice.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
Not to be confused
with BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Different products.
So we have two
bigs and two datas.
So we have BigQuery, and big
data, Datalab and Dataflow.
MARK MANDEL: I think you
mean BigQuery and Bigtable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
Oh, that's sad.
BigQuery, BigTable,
ahh, Dataflow and--
MARK MANDEL: Datalab.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Datalab.
There you go.
OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: At least none of
these names sound like Pokemon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's--
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's good.
Great.
So let's talk not
anymore about tools.
Like the tools, I think
we're pretty much done.
I'd like to talk a little
bit about what cool things
you've seen with big data.
Like what cool data sets
or what cool projects
you've heard about.
FELIPE HOFFA: OK.
The coolest one
for me, it's not--
not many people can
do things with it,
but just knowing
that people are doing
genomics stuff with BigQuery.
Solving genomics
problems with SQL.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I've
actually seen a video of you
analyzing your own genome.
FELIPE HOFFA: You saw a Tweet.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So what's genomics?
I assume it has obviously
something to do with DNA.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
So my favorite
story here is when
I met Jacquelin [INAUDIBLE],
one of our sites engineer.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: She
had joined Google
like three months previous.
And we were went
to the same event.
We said hi.
She told me that
she already knew me,
because when she was
interviewing to work at Google,
she had been watching my videos.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: And she
used one of those videos
to prepare a presentation
for her Google interview.
And that's how she got hired.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Now, I felt
it was a little unfair,
because she already knew me.
And I knew nothing of her.
So we started talking.
Then she told me about how
she loved genomics, how
she got her own 23andMe reads.
So now she had her
own genome sequence.
23andME, that's only
a small portion of it,
but [INAUDIBLE]
and she had already
loaded it into BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: And so
I asked her, whoa,
have you analyzed it?
Have you done anything with it?
She was like, not yet.
And I asked her, do you want to?
Because I already knew
what kind of queries
we could run on her genes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
a whole new meaning
to getting to know someone.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No kidding.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's cool.
MARK MANDEL: So what sort
of queries can you run?
FELIPE HOFFA: So
half-an-hour-- yeah, right.
Half-an-hour later after meeting
her, I was analyzing her genes.
MARK MANDEL: You don't
have to say the answers,
but I know you have like--
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
So there are open databases of
what each gene, what each read
means.
So you can start running joins.
Hey, let's take your special--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Specific genes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
Let's start it with
this other table
that says what each means.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's start
looking at, well, who are you?
MARK MANDEL: Who are you?
So we could be like,
all right, let's
take my genes, Francesc
genes, and see if we somehow
have a common ancestor.
FELIPE HOFFA: You probably
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
A long time ago.
MARK MANDEL: It might happen.
I don't know.
FELIPE HOFFA: Already
you have a lot in common.
Yeah, no.
But you can see things like--
you know that there are people
that cannot tolerate
eating cilantro.
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah.
I'm one of those.
Yeah.
And that's a genetic thing?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
That's a genetic.
MARK MANDEL: And
you can see it on--
FELIPE HOFFA: And
we could find--
MARK MANDEL: That's
really awesome.
FELIPE HOFFA: We
could use BigQuery
to find out the probability
of you liking cilantro.
MARK MANDEL: Now I
want to play with that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really awesome.
FELIPE HOFFA: Or can
you twist your tongue?
That's another-- that's also
qualified in your genes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
basically, that's
like if you didn't do it with
BigQuery, like that could
be a decent amount of data.
Like I don't know if
it's big data, but it's--
FELIPE HOFFA: It's a lot.
It's a lot of data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so it
could take quite a long time.
How long did it take
to run like-- to run
one query that could tell you
if I like cilantro or not?
FELIPE HOFFA: With
BigQuery it takes seconds.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Really?
FELIPE HOFFA:
Really, really fast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's cool.
FELIPE HOFFA: I had the
ability to sit down with her--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And tell her
if she likes cilantro or not.
MARK MANDEL: And so now
you know her really well.
FELIPE HOFFA: Well,
kind of in a way.
But yeah, so I had
to tweet about this.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That was--
FELIPE HOFFA: That's the one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's the one I remember.
FELIPE HOFFA: And then
William [INAUDIBLE],
our product manager
replied to that tweet.
And his tweet was, hey, I just
met you and this is crazy,
but here are my genes.
So SQL them maybe.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, wow.
Maybe I should ask
you to sing that.
dad.
But no, let's not do that.
Great.
Any other cool big data
set that you'd like to--
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, there
is so much public data,
open data available now.
And this year, I've enjoyed
playing with taxi data.
All the taxi trips in
New York and visualizing
what happens inside a city.
Or also social media sites.
Having the full story of all
the 1.9 billion Reddit comments.
MARK MANDEL: That's
a lot of data.
FELIPE HOFFA: They were
collected by a user stuck
in the matrix, on Reddit.
And then he published
the comments.
I took them and now
they're in the query.
So now we can analyze.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So are they--
are they a public data set?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Anyone can just
go and start playing with that?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, right now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
FELIPE HOFFA: Just
load BigQuery up,
use your free monthly
terabyte of analysis
and just start running queries.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
One free terabyte?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: With a T?
Wow.
MARK MANDEL: That's
a lot of data.
That's-- yeah, that's big data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: Anyone could go
and play with these datasets.
Also, Hacker News, if you
want to see the difference.
Or Gig Hub.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
We'll put a link to
that on the show notes.
That sounds really fun.
MARK MANDEL: Are
there any other places
you recommend if people
want to go looking
for big data, open set data?
Or is that giving away
your special source
of where you find your stuff?
FELIPE HOFFA: I
personally love Reddit.
I even started one
subreddit /r/BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
all the open data
sets that I know of,
that I've been playing
with-- any stories I know
of related with BigQuery--
I put in there.
MARK MANDEL: Perfect.
FELIPE HOFFA: So go
see everything I know.
Reddit /r/BigQuery.
MARK MANDEL: BigQuery.
Awesome.
Wonderful.
Well, was there
anything else that we
haven't covered that you
want to necessarily throw
in there about big data
or BigQuery or Dataflow?
FELIPE HOFFA: I guess you will
need to have me again here.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure we
can do that at some point.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I guess so.
Well, thank you so
much for being here.
And talk to you soon.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you very
much to Felipe for joining us
for this interview today.
I found that
particularly interesting.
I don't do a huge amount
of big data stuff,
so that was really great hearing
about all the products and all
the things that he's
been working on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That was lots of fun.
MARK MANDEL: Lots of fun.
But we have a really interesting
question of the week,
yet again.
Started with a conversation
I had with Andrew Watson.
He was talking about sort of
environment variables in App
Engine.
And it sort of
expanded from there
into sort of-- I've got like
a password, or a credential,
or a secret key.
You know, I need to store that
somewhere safe with the Google
Cloud Platform and
be able to share that
with a variety of services.
What sort of the
ways I can do that?
Or maybe even just what's
the best way of doing that?
Now I know you've got some
opinions on this, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I do
have some opinions.
Yeah, so it really depends on
what you are actually doing.
So I know that, for instance,
if you're in App Engine--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There is App
Engine environment variables--
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--that works very well.
But it will be available
only for App Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If
you're in Kubernetes--
MARK MANDEL: In Secrets.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There's Kubernetes secrets.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So that's
a very good solution,
when you're running
everything in Kubernetes.
But by default, my
go-to way of storing
stuff-- secrets, but
not only secrets.
Also configuration and
all of those things
that you want to
share across all
of the agents of your system,
is the metadata service.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that
sounds interesting.
Tell me more about what that is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So it's
something really simple.
It's basically a way
to store metadata.
MARK MANDEL: Like
key value pairs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Key
value pairs, exactly.
So you have a key, which is a
string; and then a value, which
is a string.
That's it.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
the good thing about it
is that it's actually very safe.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
very simple to use.
It has a REST API.
And it gives authentication.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you're
going to need some scopes
to access it, and everything.
But if you're doing it from
inside of a Compute Engine,
by default you're already
authorized to do it.
MARK MANDEL: That's nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You're actually going
to be hitting an
internal endpoint.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So even just
[? Curl ?] will work for you.
If you're doing it from
outside of Compute Engine,
you will need to use
the REST API, that
then allows you to
access the same API
but with authentication.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
So I only thought you
could access the metadata
stuff basically from within
Google Compute Engine.
But you saying,
like, we can actually
access that from anywhere?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I did that too.
I did think so, too.
And actually, while
preparing this podcast,
one of our colleagues,
Sandeep, showed us
that we were wrong,
which is awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That's great.
I love being wrong.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It actually makes--
it makes your life much easier.
Basically, you just keep all
your data in the Compute Engine
metadata service and
you can access it
from wherever you want.
MARK MANDEL: That's
really, really handy.
Just add whatever
you want in there
and you just need
to know it's secure.
It's encrypted both
ways and on storage too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
incredibly simple.
Yeah.
It's encrypted.
And not only a REST.
So once we store it, we store it
encrypted, but also in transit.
So while it's going from the
service to your instance,
it will also be encrypted there.
So it's really,
really simple to use.
If you had other-- other things
that you wanted to share,
like there were like--
imagine it's not just
something quite small.
It's, I don't know, a
big file or something
that you want to keep
secret, then probably
Google Cloud Storage.
That just depends--
way to do it,
because then you don't have
limitations on the size.
You can keep whatever you want.
And it's also very
secure, it's encrypted.
It's going to require
you authentication,
and all of the same
things, just bigger.
MARK MANDEL: By
the same token, I
suppose you could also use
Datastore or even Cloud SQL
if you really wanted to.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: But it sounds
like the metadata API,
I mean that sounds like it's
kind of built for this stuff.
That sounds like a
really good solution.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's the
simplest way to do it.
And yeah, I guess one of
the cool things of this
is that, yeah, it also works
outside of Compute Engine,
so you can access it
through a REST API.
MARK MANDEL: That
is very, very cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, this is the last
episode of the year.
It's a shed a little
of tear moment.
I'm a little bit sad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Sadness invades me.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I'm going to miss you
for the next few weeks.
But we're definitely
coming back in 2016.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We're coming back at the
beginning of next year
for more and better.
MARK MANDEL: More and better.
We've got a very exciting
interview lined up,
but I don't want
to say what it is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're
going to keep it secret,
but I think it's going
to be really awesome.
It's a by something
that I really like!
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's so--
MARK MANDEL: It's not Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's not about Go.
MARK MANDEL: It's not about Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Yeah, it's not about Go.
Maybe we should do
something about Go.
But yeah, it's going to
be really interesting
and with someone that really
knows what he's talking about.
So I'm very excited
about this one.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds
good, sounds good.
So definitely people,
check in with us in 2016.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So let's see you in two weeks.
See you all soon.
We've finished now with
our eighth episode.
And hoping for many
more to come next year.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
We'll see you next year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See you!
MARK MANDEL: Bye.